قتل المئات واصاب الالاف وشرد ملايين
البشر زلزال مدمر كارثه كبرى وحدث جلل
اصاب سكان الاكوادور في عام 2016 بل انه
اعتبر الاسوا بين ماس متكرره عاشتها
البلاد على مر سنوات مضت
فماذا حدث
مع حلول يناير من كل عام على الناس هنا في
الساحل الاكوادوري التعامل مع تداعيات
تغيرات المناخ الناتجه عما يعرف بظاهره
النينو وما يرافقها من امطار غزيره
وفيضانات وانهيارات ارضيه لكن ما كان
ينتظرهم هذا العام شيء مختلف حدث اكبر من
المتوقع واسوا مما سبق فبعد سلسله من
الهطولات المطريه وفي السادس عشر من ابريل
ضرب زلزال مدمر شمال الاكوادور في حدث جلل
امتدت اثاره على طول الشريط الساحلي
للمحيط الهادي
سجل زلزال الذي تمركز في البحر على بعد
نحو 17 ميلا من مقاطعه مانابي ومئه ميل
شمال غرب العاصمه كيتو
7.8 درجات على مقياس ريختر
القتل هزات العنيفه الرعب في قلوب السكان
وبدات الابنيه تتراقص في مكانها سقطت
الاسطح والجدران ودفن الكثير من الاشخاص
تحت الركام في مشهد مروع هرع الناجون في
الطرقات بحثا عن اماكن تؤويهم ودوت صافرات
الخطر في ارجاء البلاد
دقائق معدوده كانت كافيه لتدمير نحو 35
الف منزل بشكل كامل او جزئي وحدوث تصدعات
كبيره بالطرق وخطوط امداد المياه
والكهرباء كما خرجت شبكات الاتصال عن
الخدمه تركزت معظم قوه الزلزال في
مقاطاعات مانطا وبدرانلس وبورتوفي وفي
منامي كما شعر سكان العاصمه كيتو بشده
الهزات فاعلنت الحكومه الاكوادوريه حاله
الطوارئ في البلاد
وتحركت فرق الانقاذ
مع استمرار الهطول المطري تسببت
الانهيارات الطينيه بمزيد من الضرر
بالبنيه التحتيه وعرقلت وصول المساعدات
هبت المنظمات المحليه والدوليه لمساعده
الالاف من المنكوبين بعد عمليات بحث طويله
تم انقاذ ما مجموعه 113 شخصا من تحت
الركام فيما فشلت في انقاذ نحو 700 اخرين
كانوا قد لقوا حتفهم في الكارثه مقابل
اكثر من سته الاف اصيبوا بجروح خطيره
مع انتهاء الكارثه ترك اكثر من 100 الف
شخص بلا ماوى واحتاج اكثر من 700 الف شخص
لمساعده فوريه فيما قدر عدد المتضررين
بشكل مباشر او غير مباشر من الزلزال بنحو
سبعه ملايين شخص اما الاضرار الماديه
فقدرت بين مليارين الى ثلاثه مليارات
دولار مع تدمير في البنى التحتيه وصل
لتسعين في المئه ببعض المناطق
في الاكوادور يعيش الناس في قلق مستمر
فخلال 120 عاما مضت حدثت سبعه زلازل على
الاقل بقوه سبع درجات او اكثر على مسافه
150 ميلا من الموقع ذاته لزلزال عام 2016
المدمر كما تسبب التوراه بركان كوتوباكسي
في جبال الانديز التي كان اخرها في عام
2015 في حدوث زلازل ايضا فيما تعاني
الدوله الساحليه من مخاطر طبيعيه اخرى
كالجفاف والفيضانات والانهيارات الارضيه
وحرائق الغابات
[موسيقى]